hey guys welcome to Co tech materials my
name is Matt and we just want to do a
quick update on this game engine thing
I've been working on and doing some
videos on and it's just kind of let you
know where it's at and what I'm doing
next at last video I talked about kind
of revamping the core underlying loop
behind how the how it all runs and I'm
still on that but I've gone a lot of
different directions and I've learned
actually quite a few things recently
about - how to better handle projects
and how to better scale them so I just
want to talk a little bit about that so
I mean just bring it over here so here's
the project it's called ancient Archer
it is a game engine and I've got a
master branch which hasn't been updated
in quite a while and if you open visual
studio if you clone it and open in
Visual Studio you'll basically notice
that it just runs a bunch of little
demos of just to make sure it's in
working so in the development a lot of
stuff has been going on it is somewhat
chaotic and I've actually let's see here
I've kind of redone let's see a lot of
things
well I started kind of revamping the way
I was doing the libraries and I was
doing it one way and then I started to
realize that I could do it another way
so it's it's in a state of transitioning
yet again so one of the big things I
want to get in this development branch
is well animations it's probably not
gonna get pushed to master until all the
libraries are done and all the animation
the new animation stuff is done and also
have some shaders stuff to work out so I
actually haven't been working on it a
whole lot I've got some past iterations
and these releases these were basically
the little demos a friend and I kind of
put together a long time ago back when I
was you know over a year ago at this
point basically I just released them at
some point because I wanted to save
their state but there it has sort of
little demos that you can you can run if
you just want to see examples of OpenGL
but there nothing really to write home
about let's see here so I guess I'll
talk about more of where it's going so
I'm just gonna launch a visual studio
here cuz that's what I've been running
this on I actually haven't been been
spending a whole lot of time on this
recently because I've been spending a
lot more time on this on some other
repos underdark tactics diem power and
just kind of messing with libraries and
building libraries which has been a lot
of fun to me recently and so I'm on the
dev branch here and as you can see we
have a lot of code over on the side and
a lot of things going on but if I look
at my my get stuff here from github I
have made some recent changes I kind of
redid all the libraries basically a
couple days ago I spent like a whole day
reanalyzing and redoing all the
libraries and it was sort of a mess so
if I go to the properties here and go to
C++ you can see all the includes there
and same with all the linkers got all
the linkers set up so I've got Open GL
GL WSDL STL mixer and
Sam for loading stuff and I've got it
all set up but it's all like manually
configured and I have found a way to not
have to manually configure all these
that is just so much better and scales
so much better so I'm gonna redo it yet
again it's uh I learned a lot we'll say
I spent like a whole day messing with
these libraries it was literally a full
day studying and figuring out how to get
them all included and I was using a
method where I would clone it with
github build it and then map it to this
and then right after I finished all that
work I learned about sub modules and
github know sub modules and github
basically allow you to do this just just
check this out all right so if you you
can't actually do it in Visual Studio so
that's that's a thing you have to open
and git bash and I'm gonna talk a lot
more about sub modules in another video
but that's where the state of this is
right now is I'm gonna sub module out
all this all this all these other
projects that all these other libraries
that I'm including in that way I don't
have to manually configure them anytime
I change them so let's just see I'm just
gonna go to it real quick it's storage
source repos matte and an ancient archer
and then we'll just check the branch
this is probably really tiny so I'm
going to zoom it way in for the vid so
you can see we have a master development
branch I'm on the development branch and
if I do get sub module there is
currently nothing so basically what you
can do is you can do get sub module add
and then you type in the repo so rather
than having to clone whatever your
library is in a different directory you
can just sub module it and anytime you
clone anytime you clone this project you
can you can do a git clone with
recursive and get all the sub module
and that way anytime you clone the
project from a new computer you can just
run get sub module or git clone project
name and then recursive and you'll get
all the sub modules it'll just build
them and the whole point of that is you
can I can just go to another computer
and with one or two commands and get I
can be ready to work on this project
whereas previously I would have to clone
this project clone all the repos
individually that it relies on make sure
they're mapped correctly and with sub
modules it's just a one-time thing so my
overall goal here is basically make this
really easy to work on and it's gonna
take some work to get to that but sub
modules seems to be about the best way
to get libraries working easily and I'm
gonna do another video on that so stay
tuned so it's basically where I'm at
with ancient Archer right now it is
still somewhat of a mess as far as what
to do this code is all gonna be changed
the modules are gonna be changed and so
stay tuned in the next video
I should have animations working too it
should have all the sub model sort it
out and I should me it should be really
easy to just clone and start working
with and I guess the next step after
that is I'm probably going to get it all
set up for SEMA cuz right now it's
visual studio only although I'm using
code that would allow you to build it on
any OS like this should work on Mac
Linux Windows but right now I only
really have it set up to run in Windows
and also as it is on this development
branch I kind of put a little kind of I
literally put a little text thing here
it allows you to pick what you want to
do so I can test the base loop so it
doesn't just pop up windows on you
without you knowing what's going on
which is basically what it was doing
previously in this base loop just just
make sure that I have a loop actually
works give you a bunch of updates about
what's going on so if I pause it and go
to this window you can see what it's
doing I'm basically got a bunch of C
outstay what's going on and let's see
into quit we just close the window let
me hit now I stop in here
so if I go to demo world this is
actually pretty not this is not right
currently but I've you know one of the
biggest things about this that probably
and I've said it before and the opengl
stuff kind of wonky I'm gonna make that
a lot better I might even do something
else with it but I think I'm gonna stick
with OpenGL for now as you can see it's
not loading the textures and colors
right and some of the lights isn't quite
right and that's all that's a shader
problem not that's not really what I'm
focused on but all the windowing and
input is it's pretty nice so I'm really
happy with that I've just been kind of
putting off the rendering aspect because
I really like structuring things and
getting things nice and smooth but as
you can see I can press tab and then I
get a mouse control so it's pretty easy
to set up for hey you're in a game here
and maybe you want to go into your
inventory so you press the button to go
to your inventory your first person here
I'm gonna go to your inventory and get
your mouse you can do that and it tells
you your mouse location over on the
console just as a sample so we could
register clicks oh I also I've sound so
if I left click I don't know if you can
hear that I don't think it's picking up
my audio but yeah I have a couple left
click right click to make some sounds
just a little sound demo so everything
actually works pretty good just need to
sort out like you know just basically
need to organize it a little better and
let's see our PG game there's nothing
even there and I can just quit alright
so I yeah I'm basically just gonna the
next steps here reorganize get all the
libraries sorted out fix the rendering
fix the animations it's a whole lot of
fixing and I basically have to be in the
right mood or mentality to start
restructuring - for me to really do that
but I've been really kind of interested
in other things and messing with other
things and it's nice to have a nice
fresh project to test out some of these
methods and some of these new library
things before I dive in and start hiding
it in on here like even this random I
have a library for random now that I can
just sub-module in rather than have this
whole random file so ultimately these
are going to get deleted
and I'm gonna a sub-module and the
random heck I'll do that right now
actually just as a little sample so I'm
gonna remove all this random stuff get
it out of here and let me just
sub-module and the random so you guys
can kind of see that get sub-module okay
I'm in the right one I'm in development
okay sub-module add and let me get my
random director here gonna be a sec here
it is here's my repos got a bunch of
stuff going on here I'm searching for
Rand in this user so brand isn't
anything is that special other than it's
a DLL for randomization it if we look
take a quick peek at the code which is
going to be right here I think is most
well C header it's basically it
basically has some really basic
functions to get the randomization you
want or you can just type in a roll 1 D
2 Row 1 d 20 whatever you want to do so
it's just a library to make
randomization super easy that's really
all it is it it uses chrono and random
from the standard library and it's just
a a really nice reliable randomization
library where you don't have to rebuild
it from scratch every time so sub-module
and this would be nice so let's go to
the clone here clone copy this and we
will go back here and there we go paste
it in didn't do anything
what on earth okay so apparently it just
didn't copy interesting copy copy yes
for real copied into my clipboard all
right so get sub-module add paste we got
it alright so when you do this just an
add it go it just clones it right off
the bat there and it's ready to go now
you do have to do
a quick configuration individual studio
quick build so what I'll do next is I'll
just close this or back in here I'm
gonna hit refresh it doesn't see
anything so you have to do in your
solution here is you got to right-click
and do an add existing project now I was
a see make project you got to do the see
make thing first so you can get the
solution in in there but otherwise you
can just go let's see I'm going on
ancient Archer
I will now see Rand in here because I
sub module within I'll see it here and
there's the project so I'll just hit
open here and boom there we go and now
I'll go back to this engine file over on
the right side right click it and go to
add reference now I just want to
reference Rand because he uses random
and that handles everything I don't need
to do any more configuring I don't need
to right-click and go into properties
and do a bunch of stuff that's what's so
nice about this is it just takes away
all the manual config and now when I hit
build it's automatically gonna build
this library if I need it and apparently
I just always get messages as soon as I
record it happens every time
ah it didn't it's not it's a whatever I
guess I should just mute my stuff before
I hit record but I never remember to do
that so we have all the the
randomization in here and now the
important thing about this is when I go
to commit the changes for this project
since Rand is a sub module it it doesn't
it's not gonna show it as the get
changes it's its own little project so
yeah well I'll do more on sub modules
later but that's just a really nice way
to clean up your project and not have to
manually include things you can just
sub-module them in and then reference it
and it's literally that simple and that
it that way you can really we'll save
you a lot of time you won't have to work
with package managers all that I really
like it so far but I'm still
experimenting on that okay well I guess
that's enough on this I guess so
actually I'll finish so if I build right
now it's gonna have an error because
it's not probably not gonna see all the
random stuff yeah one thing
doesn't see the random so now this is
just gonna be deleted and I'm gonna
include it from that other project so I
should kind of Auto see all this where
am i using random right here so if I
right-click on this it's no longer a a
so longer that it's no nor any of this
so I'm gonna have to do a little bit of
code updating here but now it should see
this in 2k random from the reference
project so when I do it right clicking
you know the quick actions refactoring
should I shouldn't have the option to
include it and there it is is this the
right one though I don't know I guess I
could do a quick oops I could quickly
find out by doing something like this
going in here and I actually don't need
this here anymore so I'm just delete it
and now it shouldn't see that at all and
if I right click and include it save
again now it should be happy yeah so
let's hit build again and I should still
be able to have my randomization this is
just a randomization of throwing those
boxes around so if I look at demo world
I'm still getting randomized boxes now
from that grande do a library that I
just sub-module din and I no longer have
to maintain and mess with the module
separately in a bunch of different
places it's just that one repo for all
the projects if this gets updated it'll
get updated along with all the projects
however you do have to update it
manually and I think if I remember
correctly it's like get sub module
update I think it's all you do and if
there's any any new updates for it on
the project it'll pull them down next
time you build it'll take it so that's
where this project is going I've got a
lot of work to do like I mentioned
libraries rendering structure I'm still
planning on keeping it a scripting
engine and I might actually just end up
turning it into a game instead of an
engine I don't know about it being a
namja engine right now it's just a
basically an engine where you can lamda
in everything about how your world works
all right well I'm out see you guys the
next episode I hope you enjoy this let
me know what you think down below don't
forget to Like and subscribe for more
coding and tech stuff peace out